mais un nom mais un moment c'est pas
extensibles à regarder là ce soir on qui
on enlèverait qui on enlèverait bas
voilà qui on enlèverait personnes tout
le monde est excellent donc personne
donc vous l'avez dont béthune agile il
était derrière et qui peut-être qu il
croit jean bernard côté on peut pas voir
50 chroniqueur yann et a même pas qu'il
se soit rué mails étant très bien et
argile est bas
mais vraiment vous êtes très bien ce
soir voilà arrêté très belle et là vous
êtes très bien ce soir isabelle on ne
peut pas la déplacer mais
c'est compliqué
le seul à la limite
une actuelle
j'étais sûr déçu je vous emmerde
non mais c'est vrai le seul à l'amitié
c'est vrai en plus je me faisais moi
quand je regarde les messins athée je me
dit celui qui font enlever c'est mon
tienne on
va faire un tour de table
mathieu question tu tu enlèves n'est que
c'est enlever quelqu'un serait qui ce
soir là on parlera moins que le coeur
battant de casta
merci
sophy je réfléchis il faut que ce soit
un mec pour qui tu veux comme ça on est
un peu au repos à la
maison m'a dit que c'était pour tours
mais je veux dire mon programme isa si
on la met au repos une fois quoi sur
castres
voilà qu'on ne peut pas la mettre au
fond c'est comme un ace et comme quand
ton vélo tu es dans une croûte et dans
une montée tu dois continuer d'agir
situtala apprécié la descente aux enfers
et non c'est plus le terminal en lave
bien sûr canal vie bada est rentré jeudi
réguler par principe non guillaume il
est bon valence kelly moi je dirais mon
crétin avec bernard
et l'autre on a l'impression d'être amer
au pays de constituer des crétins les
cas c'est mal
je m'en vais le dire au petit prince est
connu
oui raymond bernard mois comme l'a dit
valérie et ça tourne jamais moi j'aurais
sorti un pays alors elle tourne mais
auront-elles jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible
genre à me jean rémy peut-être delphine
ou pernikoff ont lu et monique et
tuba tv avec la vie comme on sait plus
où il est
alors oui même mois valérie commence
enfin les choses proprement et bim
évidemment raymond non pourquoi ben
parce que tu sais rien
[Applaudissements]
c'est juste une barge en stupide
[Rires]
le numéro un mondial la tête de série le
génie matthieu delormeau gauche il faut
juste qu'ils en fassent au nom 3 et
après vous quitter je sais qu'il ya
quelqu'un dans ce qu'il fait 25 ans que
je me galles sera temps
[Applaudissements]
guillaume moi je me lèverai mois pour
jean-michel non mais non mais c'est pas
pour maintenant et c'est comme faire la
fausse modestie mais chauffeur non c'est
pas pour faire le [ __ ] je trouve qu'il
est bien meilleur il est au dessus tout
le monde comme gilles comme mathieu et
c'est pas
le même temps qu'ils valideront céderait
d'ipad but d'apporter les gens touchent
à la question que vous régliez bon la
série la série le temps qu'un d'entre
nous on aura le norad le final tête donc
ces boues bah oui je vous enlevez aller
mais allez-y
[Applaudissements]
ouais il a raison et on partout tu t'en
prendre
et les mutuelles barils
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]